This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个 iHeart 播客。绝对真人。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。在这个奇怪的现代世界里，我将为你剖析精神坚韧、健身以及培养韧性的秘诀。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《2%》。也就是数字 2%。“Look Back at It”播客节目。1979 年，对我来说那是意义重大的一年。84 年对我来说也很重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及我们最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊 80 年代。84 年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听“Look Back at It”。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一位经验丰富的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着铠甲？这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023 年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦女士，你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试报告，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean.
迈克尔·兰吉尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨 20 多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. We're tackling a new subject today, one we've never really dove into, and that is the power of staying present, the power of mindfulness of living in the moment. For I guess anyone who's ever been told to just enjoy the moment, to just appreciate what you have right now, you'll kind of understand that doing so is actually a lot harder than it looks. The present feels very, very elusive in so many ways, especially
大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到这个播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能来到这里，收听又一期节目，当然，我们要剖析的是 20 多岁的心理学。今天我们要探讨一个新的主题，一个我们从未真正深入研究过的主题，那就是保持当下的力量，活在当下的正念的力量。我想，对于任何被告知“享受当下”、“好好珍惜你现在拥有的一切”的人来说，你们大概都会明白，这样做其实比看起来要难得多。在很多方面，当下感觉非常非常难以捉摸，尤其是
when we're facing so many distractions and our attention is being pulled in so many directions. We're being told to kind of do it all. When was the last. time within that system and within that kind of busyness culture that we've actually slowed down and had a look around us and appreciated where we are right now. We're also really inclined to, I think, ruminate on the past a lot naturally, but also to overthink and stress about the future. And what I've, you know, at least come to find myself is that we spend a lot more time appreciating the moment only when it's past, only in hindsight, rather than when we're in it. And that can really come at our detriment, as we'll come to see.
当我们面临如此多的干扰，注意力被拉向四面八方的时候。我们被告知要面面俱到。在这个系统和这种忙碌文化中，你上一次真正放慢脚步、环顾四周并珍惜当下是什么时候？我想，我们也很容易自然而然地沉溺于过去，但同时也容易对未来过度思考和感到压力。而我所发现的，至少是我自己最终发现的是，比起身处其中的时候，我们往往只有在事情过去之后，只有在事后诸葛亮时，才会更多地去感激那个时刻。正如我们即将看到的，这实际上可能会对我们造成损害。
Letting yourself be present, be deliberately conscious of all that you're experiencing and really noticing small things about your reality brings a lot of peace that we tend to neglect in our really busy lives. It's also been said to be amazing for creativity, mental clarity, productive. and just all around general levels of happiness, which who doesn't want more of that? But mindfulness again doesn't always come easy. And that's why I think it's really valuable to start almost training our brains in being mindful when we're young or during our 20s when it does tend to have the biggest and longest impact. And that is precisely what we're going to discuss today,
让自己活在当下，刻意意识到你所经历的一切，并真正注意到你现实生活中的微小事物，会带来一种平静，而这种平静往往在我们忙碌的生活中被我们所忽略。据说它对创造力、精神清晰度、生产力以及整体的幸福感都有着惊人的提升作用，谁不想拥有更多这些呢？但正念同样并非易事。这就是为什么我认为，趁我们还年轻，或者在我们通常会产生最大、最持久影响的 20 多岁时，开始训练我们的大脑保持正念是非常有价值的。而这正是我们今天要讨论的内容，
the immense power of staying present, why we tend to struggle to do so, and what we can kind of learn from the experts on how to keep your feet really firmly planted in the now. And I'm also going to kind of introduce you to this like, kind of like a 30 second introduction into this art of living in the moment, into a practice that helps you bring you into the moment that I personally really love. I actually use it on a daily. and I think this is a great place to kind of introduce people to it.
保持当下的巨大力量，我们为什么往往难以做到这一点，以及我们可以从专家那里学到什么，从而让我们的双脚坚定地扎根于当下。我还想向大家介绍一种方法，类似于对这种活在当下艺术的 30 秒介绍，一种能帮你融入当下的练习，我个人非常喜欢。我实际上每天都在使用它，我认为这是向人们介绍它的绝佳切入点。
It's an amazing method and hopefully you get something out of it. So I really hope you enjoy this episode. I hope it is your calling or something to remind you to be more present in your life to stop trying to rush to the future, rush to the next chapter or get too stuck in what's already come. I know it's something that I sometimes really need a reminder of, especially right now, you know, in recent months, I feel like the older you get, right? Like time just seems to speed up a little bit and that's a really scary thought at times.
这是一个神奇的方法，希望你能从中有所收获。所以我真心希望你喜欢这一集。我希望它能成为你的呼唤或某种提醒，提醒你在生活中要更加活在当下，停止试图急于走向未来、急于进入下一个篇章，或者过分纠缠于已经过去的事情。我知道有时候我真的需要这样的提醒，尤其是最近几个月，你知道的，随着年龄的增长，对吧？时间似乎总是过得更快一点，有时这真是一个可怕的想法。
But being really mindful of where you are now and the privilege of getting to experience where you are now definitely is grounding and definitely brings us back. And I think we all need that sometimes. So I'm very excited to share my thoughts, the psychology, the studies that we've dug up for this one. So without further ado, let's get into the power of staying present. Staying present and enjoying the moment is something that I will come out and say I really, really struggle with. I have struggled with it for many years because of how I think chaotic my
但真正意识到你现在所在的位置以及能够体验现状的特权，绝对能让人脚踏实地，也绝对能把我们拉回现实，我想我们有时都需要这种感觉。所以我非常高兴能分享我的想法、心理学知识以及我们为这一期节目挖掘的研究成果。闲话少说，让我们切入保持当下的力量。我必须坦白，保持当下的力量和享受当下是我非常、非常难以做到的事情。多年来我一直在与之斗争，因为我认为我的
thoughts always seem to be or just the fact that there's always something going on. There's always something to overthink, which is all too common amongst any one of you, any one of us who struggles with anxiety or just has a lot of things on their mind or a really busy life. What's really helped me though is being a... able to categorize the different distractions or interruptions that make me feel distanced from the present. And when I say distanced from the present, what I really mean is I'm spending a lot more time in my brain than in my senses, a lot more time in kind of fantasy or memory or overthinking than I am in what's actually going on around me. And it kind of feels like there's the static
思绪似乎总是那么混乱，或者只是因为总是有各种各样的事情在发生。总有事情需要过度思考，这对于你们当中任何一个与焦虑作斗争，或者只是满脑子事情、生活非常忙碌的人来说，都是太常见不过了。然而，对我有很大帮助的是……能够对那些让我感到疏离当下的各种干扰或打扰进行分类。当我说“疏离当下”时，我真正想说的是，我花在头脑中的时间远多于花在感官上的时间，我花在幻想、回忆或过度思考上的时间，远多于花在周围实际发生的事情上的时间。这感觉就像我的生活和之间隔着一层静电，
between me and my life or that I'm walking through life and not really able to remember what has happened. That really for me is a good indication that I'm feeling a little bit detached. And there seems to be three ways in which that kind of happens in which we disconnect. The first way is when we get stuck in the past falling into the nostalgia trap or the regret spiral. If you've listened to our full episode on the psychology of nostalgia. You'll probably know a lot about this, but nostalgia is one way that we definitely become unable to appreciate our present because we are very much enticed by the more rosy memories of the past. Regret is another emotion that I mentioned, feeling like you can't stop reliving moments of embarrassment or cringe. And then of course we have trauma, reliving trauma, feeling
或者我走过生活却记不清到底发生了什么。对我来说，这确实是一个我感到有些抽离的好迹象。这种脱节或发生断连的方式似乎有三种。第一种方式是当我们陷入过去，落入怀旧陷阱或遗憾漩涡。如果你听过我们关于怀旧心理学的完整单集，你可能对此深有体会，但怀旧绝对是我们无法欣赏当下的一种方式，因为我们极易被过去更加美好的回忆所吸引。遗憾是我提到的另一种情绪，感觉自己无法停止重温那些尴尬或让人脚趾抠地的时刻。当然，还有创伤，重温创伤，感觉自己不断被某些痛苦的经历拉回记忆中。其中许多具体的、可以说是对当下的干扰，都归结为未解决的情感体验，你知道的，
constantly pulled into your memories by some really painful experience. And a lot of these specific kinds of, I would say, distractions from the present come down to unresolved emotional experiences that, you know, there isn't a place for them to rest. There isn't, your brain hasn't fully gotten through processing what you've been through, a situation, and so it continues to kind of remain in your active memory. The second category is when we get fixated on the future. Now this is definitely where I spend a lot of my time. Much of what ruins the present is sheer anxiety.
它们无处安放。你的大脑还没有完全处理完你所经历的事情、某种情境，因此它继续残留在你的活跃记忆中。第二类是我们对未来产生执念。这绝对是我花了很多时间的地方。毁掉当下的很大一部分原因纯粹是焦虑。
For me, this really includes anxiety and worry about what needs to be done. Like, you know, you're trying to talk to a friend or a co-worker. You're trying to be engaged in that conversation. And all you can think about is how much work you need to do or your endless to-do list, overthinking future choices and outcomes, and even some of those more existential questions that can create a great deal of detachment, if not disassociation at the time. Of course, I think disassociation is kind of in a league of its own here.
对我来说，这确实包括对需要完成的事情的焦虑和担忧。就像，你知道的，你正试图和朋友或同事交谈。你试图投入到那场对话中。而你脑子里想的却全是你需要完成多少工作，或者你那无穷无尽的待办事项清单，过度思考未来的选择和结果，甚至是一些更具存在主义的问题，如果在当时，这些都会产生很大程度的疏离感，甚至解离感。当然，我认为解离感在这里可以说是自成一格。
For those of us who aren't familiar with the term, it's this experience where we feel completely disconnected from our thoughts, our feelings, memories, surroundings, sense of self, basically everything that makes up the present. And sometimes we can feel disconnected just for a few seconds or much, much longer. And it's a really scary experience to have to feel like you're almost floating outside of your body or that nothing feels real. Often it's the result of too much stress or extensive trauma. our brain is kind of trying to find a way to essentially protect itself to compartmentalize and to
对于那些不熟悉这个词的人来说，这是一种我们感觉自己完全与思想、感情、记忆、周围环境、自我意识，也就是构成当下的所有一切完全脱节的体验。有时，我们会感到这种断连仅仅持续几秒钟，或者更长、更长时间。这种感觉非常可怕，仿佛你漂浮在自己的身体之外，或者一切都变得不真实。通常这是压力过大或长期创伤的结果。我们的大脑试图找到一种方法来本质上保护自己，进行区隔，并且
survive when it can't handle that much information or that much stress or trauma. And finally, I think on a less extreme note, we just have general everyday distractions. Now, when I say distractions, I mean both emotional and physical distractions or preoccupations is maybe a better word. We can think of things like notifications from our phone, a really busy environment, as kind of falling into this category. And our phones are, I think, a big problem point for many of us
当它无法处理那么多信息、压力或创伤时，借此求生。最后，我想在一个不那么极端的层面上，我们只是有一些日常的普遍干扰。现在，当我谈到干扰时，我的意思是情感和身体上的干扰或全神贯注，用这个词可能更贴切。我们可以把诸如手机通知、非常忙碌的环境之类的事情看作是属于这一类。而且我认为手机对我们许多人来说是一个很大的问题点，
because they are just simply designed to be so addictive. That was an intentional choice by their creators. And they can really start to feel like our whole reality at times because of how reliant we are on them and the dependency that we have, whereby we're constantly drawn to them for everything from social connection to work, shopping, entertainment, information. I think every single one of us has unknowingly missed out on a beautiful moment
因为它们的设计就是如此容易让人上瘾。这是其创造者刻意做出的选择。由于我们对它们的极度依赖，以及我们对它们产生的依赖性，它们有时真的开始感觉像是我们的全部现实，以至于我们不断被它们吸引，从社交联系到工作、购物、娱乐、信息，无所不包。我想我们每个人都在不知不觉中错过了一个美好的时刻，
because we were locked in by our screens. We have missed an old friend walking by us. We've missed seeing some beautiful interaction take place. Or we've missed really feeling what we're feeling because as soon as it gets too much or uncomfortable, we pick up our phones and we flood our brains with information as a buffer. In fact, a recent report from the American Psychological Association, it actually suggests that our phones often divert our attention away from the real world, which, duh.
因为我们被屏幕锁死了。我们错过了一个老朋友从身边走过。我们错过了一些美丽互动的发生。或者我们错过了真实地感受自己的感受，因为一旦这种感觉变得太多或令人不适，我们就会拿起手机，用信息充斥大脑作为缓冲。事实上，美国心理学会最近的一份报告表明，我们的手机经常将我们的注意力从真实世界中转移开，这简直是废话。
But the reason it does that is because it kind of takes our attention from this messy reality into this nice, neatly formed and neatly designed reality where we know what to expect. Our apps have everything in place. We are in control. And so it becomes kind of a mental sanctuary. And what's the consequence of this? Well, a separate study from 2020 basically found that because our phones are constantly capturing our attention, a lot of us do feel less socially connected.
但它之所以这样做，是因为它把我们的注意力从这个杂乱无章的现实，转移到了这个漂亮、整洁、设计精良、我们知道会发生什么的现实中。我们的应用把一切都安排妥当。我们掌控一切。因此，它变成了一种精神庇护所。这会带来什么后果呢？嗯，2020 年的一项独立研究基本上发现，由于手机不断夺走我们的注意力，我们中的许多人确实感到社交联系减少了。
We are less able to recall certain memories, especially biographical memories. And we feel less in the moment. And you know what? I read that study and I was kind of. of like, do we even need a study to tell us that? Like, who hasn't felt this way or question their relationship with our phone or social media in the last couple of years? Like, I think all of us are probably getting to the point where we realize that what's really keeping us separate from our experiences in a lot of circumstances is a screen. You can kind of see that there
我们回忆某些记忆的能力变差了，尤其是自传体记忆。我们感觉更难活在当下。你知道吗？我读了那项研究，当时就想，难道我们还需要一项研究来告诉我们这一点吗？谁在过去几年里没有过这种感觉，或者没有质疑过自己与手机或社交媒体的关系？我想我们所有人大概都开始意识到，在很多情况下，真正把我们与生活体验隔开的是一块屏幕。你可以看出这里
is a bit of a spectrum or a scale here from intense distractions, very extensional distractions, to smaller ones, and then those that are a bit less common and those that are very chronic. Of course, our phones are a chronic distraction, I think, or even like overthinking about the future may also be a chronic distraction. But, you know, there is, of course, a distinction between complete dissociation and getting caught up and scrolling on your phone or distracted by something in your environment. But they all have the same effect at the end of the day. We feel less in engaged in the moment. And when that continues to happen, we feel less engaged in our lives. Moments make up our lives. If you've ever had the experience of kind of waking up one day and feeling
存在着某种光谱或刻度，从强烈的干扰、极端的干扰，到较小的干扰，再到那些不那么常见以及非常慢性的干扰。当然，我们的手机是一种慢性的干扰，我想，甚至对未来的过度思考也可能是一种慢性的干扰。但是，当然，彻底解离与沉迷于刷手机或被环境中的某事分散注意力之间是有区别的。但归根结底，它们都有着同样的效果。我们对当下的投入度降低了。当这种情况不断发生时，我们对生活的投入感也会减少。时刻构成了我们的生活。如果你曾经有过这样一种体验：有一天醒来，感觉
like you can't remember what you really did for the last two weeks or two months of your life, sometimes even years, that is a consequence of day-to-day disengagement with the present for whatever a reason because remaining present really means remaining deliberately conscious of what is happening around you so that you can actually feel your life, participate fully in your life. And that also means being connected to both good and bad experiences and choosing to feel both because you appreciate that they make up this reality that you have the privilege of experiencing even during times when it doesn't feel like a privilege. Being present is not about cherry picking when you want to be present and when you want to detach,
自己记不清过去两周或两个月的人生里到底做了什么，有时甚至几年记不清，这就是无论出于何种原因，日常生活中与当下脱节的后果，因为保持真正意味着对周围发生的事情保持刻意的意识，这样你才能真正感受生活，充分参与生活。这也意味着要同时连接好与坏的体验，并选择去感受这两者，因为你感激它们构成了这个现实，即使在感觉不到这是一种特权的时期，你也有幸体验这个现实。活在当下并不是指挑肥拣瘦，挑选你想活在当下的时刻和你想抽离的时刻，
because eventually it becomes very hard to reattach when your modus operatum or your impulse is to distract and intellectualize and withdraw instead of feel. So it's showing up for all of it. And I know I said the good and the bad, but I should also include the boring within that as well. there is a lot of joy to be found in the monotonous, in my opinion. But when it becomes very routine and same old, same old, the natural urges, of course, to disengage because you don't need to be fully there. You can be thinking about other things.
因为最终，当你的惯常模式或冲动是分心、理智化和退缩，而不是去感受时，重新建立连接会变得非常困难。所以，这是要为这一切全力以赴。我知道我提到了好的和坏的，但我也应该把无聊的时刻包括在内。在我看来，在单调乏味中也能发现许多乐趣。但当它变得非常公式化、千篇一律时，自然的冲动当然是选择抽离，因为你不需要全身心投入。你可以去想别的事情。
But those boring, mindless tasks like brushing your teeth, like your daily commute, cleaning your house, answering emails, they make up a lot of life. There is a lot of minutes in those small activities. we can disengage from. And so if we're not appreciating them, if we're not immersed in them as much as we can be, that becomes a big chunk of life that we spend inwards and removed. And there's a lost opportunity in there for presence
但那些无聊、不用动脑的任务，比如刷牙、日常通勤、打扫屋子、回邮件，占据了生活很大一部分。这些小活动中包含着大量的分钟。我们可以从中抽离。因此，如果我们不珍视它们，如果我们没有尽可能地沉浸其中，那就会成为生活中的很大一部分，我们在其中向内封闭，与世隔绝。而这其中就错失了活在当下、
and for connection with our senses and with our reality. I think sometimes daydreaming and kind of indulging in old memories or make-believe situations, it can be protective, firstly in the case of boredom, but also when our current day-to-day is just not very satisfying. It's kind of a small reprieve to imagine the day's life will be better or to think about the times when it was before. That kind of emotional detachment from day-to-day is instinctual
与我们的感官和现实建立连接的机会。我认为有时候白日梦和沉溺于旧日回忆或虚构情境中，具有保护作用，首先是为了应对无聊，但也是在我们的日常生活并不十分令人满意时的一种保护。想象一下生活会变得更好的一天，或者回想过去美好的时光，这算是一种短暂的喘息。这种与日常生活的精神脱离是本能的，
and some would say hard-wired in as a way to keep our mind distracted from what could be a pretty confronting reality. And isn't that why kind of all of us go through periods of detachment? because if we were to be truly seeing our life what it was, the problems, the fears, the relationships, the insecurities, it would just be too much. It would be too painful. And so we do need a little bit of like, we need to step back mentally sometimes. Plain and simple, we just have a natural tendency to withdraw and want to skirt the unpleasant emotions and experiences because they make us uncomfortable. And logically, by avoiding this discomfort, we can be happier.
有人会说这是天生硬编码在基因里的，目的是让我们的思想分心，不去面对那些可能相当令人痛苦的现实。难道不是因为这个，我们所有人才会经历脱离期吗？因为如果我们真的去正视生活的本来面目，看到那些问题、恐惧、人际关系、不安全感，那真的会让人不堪重负。那会太痛苦了。所以我们确实需要有一点，有时我们需要在精神上退后一步。简而言之，我们就是有一种天然的倾向，想要退缩，想要避开那些令人不快的痛苦情绪和经历，因为它们让我们感到不舒服。按逻辑来说，通过逃避这种不适，我们可以获得更快乐的
longer. Isn't that the way that it goes? Unfortunately, that's an incorrect assumption. Unfortunately, it goes a different way. Actually, we don't become happier by selectively experiencing our lives. We become quite numb. And that is exactly what I was talking about before, going weeks, feeling like you've been wrapped in bubble wrap, that nothing is really touched to you or made you feel, not being able to remember conversations with friends, not being able to enjoy the moment because we have become accustomed. to this habit of either not fully feeling or feeling through our phones, only feeling through the memory of something, or, you know, my least favorite, overthinking everything that could
生活。难道事情不该是这样的吗？不幸的是，这是一个错误的假设。不幸的是，情况并非如此。事实上，通过有选择地体验生活，我们并不会变得更快乐。我们会变得相当麻木。这正是我之前所说的，连续几个周，感觉自己被包裹在气泡膜里，没有什么能真正触动你或让你有所感触，无法记住与朋友的对话，无法享受当下，因为我们已经习惯了
happen might happen that we can't control until we just don't feel anything anymore. We only think about the feeling. But when we switch to a more present mindset, we unlock some pretty profound psychological benefits. being present is a combination of awareness, acceptance, and attention. We need to be in tune with the moments that we are not present. We need to accept why that may be, whether it's an internal resistance to our feelings or a distraction, and then we need to redirect our attention from inwards to outwards. That is really complemented by just the simple art of noticing, observing your surroundings,
这种习惯：要么不完全去感受，要么通过手机去感受，只通过某事的回忆去感受，或者，你知道我最讨厌的，对所有可能发生、可能会发生、我们无法控制的事情过度思考，直到我们再也感受不到任何东西。我们只去思考这种感觉。但当我们转变为更加活在当下的心态时，我们会解锁一些非常深远的心理益处。活在当下是意识、接纳和注意力的结合。我们需要与我们不在当下的时刻保持同频。我们需要接纳为什么会这样，无论是对内心情感的抗拒还是分心，然后我们需要将注意力从向内转向向外。这真正相辅相成的是简单的注意力的艺术，观察周围环境，
really experiencing them the sounds the smells the sensations the temperature and also what you're feeling internally presence to me is also about you know surrender surrendering to what might be uncomfortable what you might not want to think about what might be happening and just being quite stoic about it like yeah this is what's happening right now and it and i have to be empathetic with myself and you know it might be hard but that's reality and i would rather be present for my reality than kind of reach a point where i can't remember anything at all when we're able to do that we become more empathetic we're more able to connect with others on a deeper level because we're actually listening we're actually absorbing everything that they're saying and doing we improve our
真正体验它们——声音、气味、感觉、温度，以及你内心的感受。在我看来，活在当下也是关于……臣服。臣服于可能让你感到不舒服的事物，臣服于你可能不想思考的事物，臣服于可能正在发生的事物，并且对此保持相当坚韧的态度，就像，“是的，这正是当下正在发生的事情，我必须对自己保持同理心，你知道，这可能会很难，但这就是现实，我宁愿为我的现实活在当下，也不愿达到那种完全什么也记不起来的境地”。当我们能够做到这一点时，我们会变得更有同理心，我们能够以更深层次的水平与他人建立联系，因为我们真正在倾听，我们真正在吸收他们所说和所做的一切。我们通过将一切放慢到仅仅发生在这里和现在的时刻，来提升思维的清晰度，
mental clarity by slowing everything down to just what's happening right now not you yesterday, not one minute from now, not a year from now, meaning that we can, you know, sideline our mental clutter and turn down the noise for a moment. And there's also been a lot of really convincing arguments about increased creativity, productivity, resilience, because those mental states, they all require a great deal of mental energy, which we often don't have the reserves for when we're bustling from one thing to the next. So there is a, you know, a real argument to be made for rest and silence and serenity in actually making us more successful and more creative and more productive and more resilient. The other significant thing about mindfulness is that it makes
不是昨天的你，不是一分钟后，也不是一年后，这意味着我们可以，你知道的，将我们的心理杂物搁置一旁，让喧嚣暂时安静下来。关于提升创造力、生产力和韧性，也有很多非常有说服力的论据，因为这些精神状态都需要大量的精神能量，当我们从一件事忙碌到另一件事时，我们往往没有足够的储备。因此，休息、沉默和宁静确实有充分的理由能让我们更成功、更有创造力、更有生产力、更有韧性。关于正念的另一个重要之处在于，它让我们
us a lot more comfortable with what we can't control. The reason we tend to spend so much time in our memories is because we already know what happened. So there is a certainty there. There are no surprises, which really eases our fear of the unknown. And it's the same reason we spend a lot of time overthinking the future, because our overthinking convinces us that the more we interrogate all the possible outcomes, the more prepared will be when they get there. But, you know, we probably won't be because it's never going to be like we thought it was. And mindfulness really places you squarely in the now. And we begin to realize that what will come will come. It's something we can't control. And the moment that you're in right now, you were probably worried about two to three
对那些我们无法控制的事情感到更加坦然。我们往往花那么多时间在回忆中的原因，是因为我们已经知道了发生了什么。所以那里有一种确定性。没有惊喜，这确实减轻了我们对未知的恐惧。这也是我们花很多时间过度思考未来的原因，因为我们的过度思考说服了我们：我们对所有可能结果的审视越多，当我们到达那里时就会准备得越充分。但是，你知道，我们大概不会准备得更充分，因为事情永远不会像我们想象的那样。而正念真正让你稳稳地处于现在。我们开始意识到，该来的总会来。这是我们无法控制的。而你现在身处其中的这个时刻，你可能在两到三个
months ago, but you're here and when you look around, it's not as scary. It's not as dangerous. You have the skills that you need to kind of get through it. And of course, the final benefit of being mindful, the true power of being present is that it just simply makes us happier. And the reason we know this comes from one of the most powerful studies of the past 10 years in my mind by this research, called Matt Killing'sworth. So his study took a huge sample of individuals, 15,000 people from different education levels, age, occupation, income, marital status. He took, you know, he sampled them from across 80 different countries. And his premise was really simple. Throughout the day, at random times, participants were contacted through their phones by an app that he had designed for
月前还在为之担忧，但你现在在这里，当你环顾四周时，它并不是那么可怕。它并没有那么危险。你拥有度过难关所需的技能。当然，保持正念的最后一个好处，活在当下的真正力量，在于它能让我们更快乐。我们之所以知道这一点，是因为在我看来，过去 10 年中最有力的研究之一，由这位名叫马特·基林斯沃思的研究人员进行。因此，他的研究选取了巨大的样本，涵盖来自不同教育水平、年龄、职业、收入、婚姻状况的 15000 名个人。他抽取了，你知道的，来自 80 个不同国家的样本。他的前提非常简单。在一天中，在随机的时间里，参与者通过他为此项研究设计的应用程序与手机取得联系，
this specific study and they were kind of asked to rate their current level of happiness, what activity they were involved in and whether or not their mind had been wandering from the activity. Now, most people know the study is the one that basically determined that money is correlated to happiness. So if this sounds familiar to you, that's the primary I think finding that people like to highlight in the media, but the finding that I find much more powerful, and the one that came from this study was that actually when it came to our attention and awareness was what really made people happy had far less to do with what they were doing and significantly more to do with whether their attention was fully present in the moment.
并被要求评估他们当前的幸福水平、他们所参与的活动以及他们的思绪是否已经从活动中游离。现在，大多数人知道这项研究是因为它基本上确定了金钱与幸福相关。所以如果这听起来很熟悉，我认为这是人们喜欢在媒体上强调的主要发现，但我发现更有力、且来自这项研究的发现是，当谈到我们的注意力和意识时，真正让人感到快乐的东西，与他们在做什么远没有那么大关系，而与他们的注意力是否完全集中在当下有显著得多的关系。
People who focused on their present moment experience, whatever was happening, even if it wasn't that great, were significantly happier than people who were allowed. allowing their mind to wander who were trying to do a million things at once. Something else he concluded was that our mind is wondering between 32 to 47% of the day, on average. But when the mind wonders, we don't feel as happy as we do in those moments of flow, attention, awareness, feeling. Because this distracted state leaves us quite vulnerable to rumination, to stress, to depression. basically like I said before we spend a great deal of time contemplating what we're feeling rather than just feeling it or we just avoid it all together which ends up giving us a lot
那些专注于当下体验的人——无论发生什么，即使不是那么好——明显比那些任由思绪游离、试图同时做一百万件事情的人要快乐得多。他得出的另一个结论是，平均而言，我们的思绪在一天中有 32% 到 47% 的时间在游离。但当思绪游离时，我们感觉不到像处于心流、注意力、意识、感受这些时刻那样快乐。因为这种分心的状态让我们极易受到反刍思考、压力、抑郁的影响。基本上，正如我之前所说，我们花大量时间去思考我们的感受，而不是去感受它，或者我们干脆彻底逃避它，这最终导致我们对所谓的负面情绪失去了很多
less mastery over our so-called negative emotions it also means that again we miss out on all the positive experiences because I said this before right if your kind of impulse your status quo is just to constantly be detached. It's hard to reattach your awareness and your attention during those good moments. So all those positive experiences that would outweigh or overwhelm the frustrating, sad, lonely ones, they're also ones that we aren't fully there for. But savoring the moment, on the other hand, and there was this brilliant study, a different study from 2017, it really talks about how when you savor the moment, the way you savor a meal, the way you savor like, a time with a friend where you savour, you know, sleeping in in the morning, that is going to make
掌控力。这也意味着，我们再次错过了所有积极的体验——因为我之前说过，对吧？如果你的一种冲动、你的现状就是不断地处于抽离状态。在那些美好的时刻，很难重新调动你的意识和注意力。因此，所有那些本可以压倒或盖过那些令人沮丧、悲伤、孤独的体验的积极体验，也是我们无法全身心投入的体验。但另一方面，细细品味当下——有一项精彩的研究，2017 年的一项不同研究，它真正探讨了当你细细品味当下时，就像品味一顿美餐、品味与朋友相处的一段时光、品味早上睡个懒觉一样，这会让你
you a lot more happier. And it's going to increase your level of daily positive emotions, which is basically a psychological scale for measuring how often we feel joyful, happy, satisfied, purposeful, grateful throughout each day. And in this study, they measured people across nine weeks and those who had more dispositional mindfulness, which meant that they were in the present more throughout their day, they did report feeling a lot more content, more able to work through their anxious thoughts, and yes, more happy.
变得更快乐。它会提高你的日常积极情绪水平，这基本上是衡量我们在每一天中感到快乐、幸福、满足、有目标感、感恩的频率的心理学量表。在这项研究中，他们对人们进行了为期九周的测量，那些具有更高倾向性正念的人——这意味着他们在一天中更多地活在当下——确实报告说感觉更加满足，更有能力度过焦虑的想法，是的，也更快乐。
One thing about that study just want to mention was this term, dispositional mindfulness, because it's something that we really do need to highlight. Basically, for some of us, it's just so much easier to exist in the present. moment. Our minds are naturally stiller, they're more serene, they're quieter in a way. That's just part of our makeup. For others, it's the opposite. And I've said this already, but I've spent a great deal of my life very anxious about something or another. And it literally used to make me feel anxious to
关于那项研究，我想提及的一点是“倾向性正念”这个词，因为这是我们确实需要强调的。基本上，对我们中的一些人来说，存在于当下
not be anxious about something because I was like, what am I missing? Some big bad fear that I haven't noticed yet. So that's how complex it is. And if you're someone like that, mindfulness is just kind of like, it just feels out of your reach. But it is very much something that we can learn. You can rewire your brain and how it operates to perceive your reality in a way that is firmly planted in the moment. And that's really what I want to discuss next. We can list all the benefits until the sun goes down. But it's semi-useless if you don't know how to get there. You don't know how to embrace the power of staying present. You don't have the techniques. So we are going to talk about all of that and of course so much more after this short break.
时刻要容易得多。我们的思绪自然更加平静，更加宁静，某种程度上也更安静。这只是我们组成的一部分。对其他人来说则恰恰相反。我之前已经说过，我生命中的很大一部分时间都对这样或那样的事情感到非常焦虑。而且，不为某事感到焦虑甚至会让我感到焦虑，因为我想：我是不是漏掉了什么？什么我还没注意到的巨大坏恐惧？这就是它的复杂性。如果你是那种人，正念对你来说就好像遥不可及。但它绝对是我们能够学习的东西。你可以重新连接你的大脑及其运作方式，以一种坚定扎根于当下的方式来感知你的现实。而这正是我想接着讨论的内容。我们可以列举出直到日落西山的各种好处，但如果你不知道如何到达那里，那就半点用也没有。如果你不知道如何拥抱保持当下的力量，你没有技巧。所以我们将在短暂的休息之后讨论所有这些，当然还有更多内容。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中。我将为你剖析精神坚韧、健身以及在这个奇怪的现代世界中培养韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。也就是数字 2%，在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 VMA 上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know.
我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集有马克·拉蒙特·希尔作客，大谈 80 年代的瘾品。需要说明的是，84 年对我的意义重大，不仅仅是因为瘾品。我随时准备一整天都在谈论瘾品，但只是让你们都知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我的意思是，马克，到了这个时候，这是我们讨论瘾品的第二集了，所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆上台面了，所以。谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, We get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域超过十年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是，特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway.
生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要。你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你纯粹只是因为想做一个好人。加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，进行关于疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标的真实对话。
Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023 年，前单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开始了长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。埃伦女士，你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试报告，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfectant. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋，迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, news, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to a love-trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. The cognitive shift required to go from someone who is constantly distracted or very self-contained, very in their own head. to someone who is in every moment, fully feeling and present, is a skill for sure, especially if your factory setting or the factory setting for your brain is one of nostalgia
随着节目的继续，新闻报道，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉诈骗罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trap》播客。从一个经常分心或非常自我封闭、总是沉浸在自己世界里的人，转变成为一个随时随地、全心感受、活在当下的人，所需的认知转变绝对是一种技能，特别是当你的出厂设置或者你大脑的出厂设置偏向于怀旧时
or anticipation or split focus. But there are a number of small things you can implement that are so minimal and yet become some of those long-term investments that we make in our life satisfaction and well-being that we wish we started earlier and that the kind of investments that people who are really happy and really successful and really at peace tend to do. And I've got to say, I don't know if you need any more convincing, but truly before I introduce these kind of methods to you, I do have to say, what do you have to lose in trying these switches? Often when we hear about mindfulness techniques or we hear about, you know, techniques for staying present that require a time investment.
或者期待，或者注意力分散。但你可以实施许多小事，它们是如此微小，却成为我们对生活满意度和幸福感的长期投资，让我们希望自己能更早开始，而且这也是那些真正快乐、真正成功、真正内心平静的人往往会做的那种投资。我必须说，我不知道你是否需要更多的说服，但在我向你介绍这类方法之前，我确实必须说，尝试这些转变你有什么好失去的呢？通常，当我们听到正念技巧，或者听到，你知道的，需要投入时间的保持当下的技巧时。
We kind of pause and we're like, is it really worth it? Do I really want to do this? My life is so busy. You know, how I'm going right now is kind of fine. So I'm just going to switch off and, yeah, I don't have time for a 30 second mindfulness exercise. That sounds silly. But I do think it's worth trialing.
我们有点停下来，然后想，这真的值得吗？我真的想这么做吗？我的生活太忙了。你知道的，我现在的生活状态还算不错。所以我打算不理会它，是的，我没有时间进行30秒的正念练习。听起来很傻。但我确实认为值得一试。
We talk about bounded and unbounded risks on the show a lot. This is a bounded risk. It takes very low. little to practice some of these methods for even 10 seconds, five minutes a day, but it could be life-changing. The person who really convinced me of this actually and why I'm so passionate about it is this man named Darren Larson, who's been practicing mindfulness for over 22 years, and he is actually a mindfulness coach. A few years back, he did this talk, and he offered this analogy. Mindfulness is like taking the stairs every day. Sometimes it's kind of annoying.
我们在节目中经常讨论有限风险和无限风险。这是一个有限风险。花哪怕每天10秒、五分钟来练习其中一些方法，所需成本非常低，但它可能是改变人生的。真正说服我这一点的人，以及我为什么对此如此热忱，其实是一个名叫达伦·拉尔森（Darren Larson）的人，他练习正念已经超过22年了，他实际上是一名正念教练。几年前，他做了一场演讲，并提出了这样一个比喻：正念就像每天走楼梯。有时候这有点烦人。
it burns, your heart rate goes up, your body is put under momentary stress, you know, the stress of confronting reality, confronting uncomfortable feelings of boredom, of loneliness, of whatever it is you're going through. But that stress trains you for future moments of tension and it makes you stronger in comparison to, you know, taking the elevator every day, which, yeah, for sure, bypasses the discomfort, but that makes you less prepared for the day the elevator is broken. and you're forced to take the stairs, you're forced to confront something in the moment, but you don't have the skills because you never practiced.
它会燃烧，你的心率加快，你的身体承受着短暂的压力，你知道的，面对现实的压力，面对无聊、孤独或无论你正在经历什么的那些不舒服的感觉。但这种压力会为你未来经历紧张时刻进行训练，与每天坐电梯相比，它会让你变得更强大，坐电梯当然可以绕过不适，但这会使你在电梯坏了的那天更加缺乏准备，你被迫走楼梯，你被迫在当下直面某些事情，但你因为从未练习过而没有这些技能。
Basically, becoming more present is about building endurance and our attentional muscles. And I love this idea of an attentional muscle because it's so visual to me. Like, I like the idea of like I can train something and make it stronger. Like, how long can I hold my senses on one thing without letting it slip? It's kind of like, how long can I hold a squat? how much can I be aware of my environment before it slips away, much like lifting weights, how much beauty can I hold? How many seconds can I go just thinking about nothing but what's in front of me? And when I started this practice, I could not go that long. It was probably like as long as I could
基本上，变得更加活在当下就是为了培养耐力和我们的注意力肌肉。我喜欢注意力肌肉这个概念，因为它对我来说太形象了。就像，我喜欢我可以训练某些东西并让它变得更强大的想法。比如，我可以把我的感官集中在一件事情上多久而不让它溜走？这有点像，我能保持深蹲多久？在我的环境溜走之前，我对它的觉察能有多少，就像举重一样，我能承载多少美？我可以连续几秒钟只想着眼前的这一切而不想别的？当我开始这项练习时，我坚持不了那么久。那大概就像我能
hold my breath. And now I feel like the same way that I go to the gym to train my muscles and my body, I really go to mindfulness to train my attention and to kind of train the part of me that experiences joy and peace. So firstly, we are going to start small. And this is a once a day, a daily practice in which you are going to deliberately, consciously, bring yourself back into the present moment for just a brief moment. I want you to set a random alarm on your phone for, I don't know, 2.33 p.m. every day. And at that time, take 30 seconds to pause and place all of your attention into the current moment. And if you don't know how to do that, there is this really simple way of doing this that was created by psychotherapist in the early 2000s, and he worked
屏住呼吸的时间一样长。现在我觉得，就像我去健身房训练肌肉和身体一样，我真正去练习正念是为了训练我的注意力，并训练我体验快乐和内心平静的那部分自我。所以首先，我们要从小事做起。这是一个每日一次的练习，你需要刻意地、有意识地将自己带回到当下，只需短短的一瞬间。我想让你在手机上为自己设置一个随机闹钟，比如说，每天下午2点33分。在那时，花30秒钟停下来，把你的全部注意力放在当下。如果你不知道该怎么做，这里有一个非常简单的方法，是由一位心理治疗师在2000年代初期创立的，他曾
in Silicon Valley with all these tech CEOs and highly successful people. And he created this thing for very busy people called the 3 by 3 by 3 method. This combines mindfulness and simplified breathing. So what I want you to do is name a physical object that you can see like a lamp, like a dresser, like a plant, and just take a deep breath in for four, hold for three, and then out for five. Then name another object in your surroundings. Do the same thing. In for four, hold for three, out for five, and then one more. You can do this not just with things that you can see, but things that you can see. that you can hear, things that you can feel like different surfaces on your body.
在硅谷与所有这些科技公司CEO和极其成功的人合作。他为非常忙碌的人创造了这个被称为3x3x3的方法。这结合了正念和简化呼吸。所以，我要你做的是，说出一个你能看到的物理物体，比如一盏灯，一个梳妆台，一株植物，然后深吸气4秒，屏气3秒，然后呼气5秒。接着说出你周围的另一个物体。做同样的事情。吸气4秒，屏气3秒，呼气5秒，然后再来一个。你不光可以用你能看到的东西来做这个，还可以用
But for that whole time that you are breathing in, holding your breath, breathing out, just focus on that one thing in your vision, in your, I don't know, in your hearing, in your, like, anywhere. Just focus on what it feels to experience that fully for three, three and three. Something that the creator of this practice, Phil Bossier says, is that when he first tells people about this, they look at him like, you know, are you spout, like you're just spouting nonsense. And then they try it. And I was one of those skeptical people because how in the world could 30 seconds shift my mindset so quickly. But the best evidence I found is the one, is the evidence that
你能听到、你能感觉到的东西来做，比如你身体上的不同表面。但在你吸气、屏气、呼气的整个时间里，只需专注于你视野中的那一个东西，在你的，我不知道，在你的听力中，在你的，比如，任何地方。只需专注于全面体验它的感觉，持续三个三秒钟。这个练习的创造者菲尔·博西尔（Phil Bossier）说过，当他第一次向人们讲述这个时，他们看着他的眼神就像是，你知道的，你在胡说八道。然后他们尝试了。我就是那些怀疑论者之一，因为30秒怎么可能这么快地改变我的心态呢？但我找到的最好证据就是那个，你可以为你自己提供的
you can provide for yourself. So I do want you to try it. And if it doesn't work, that's 30 seconds. You would have spent listening to this episode anyway. So you don't really have much to lose. But if it does, if you feel even the slightest change, the slightest change, the slightest transformation, try implementing it for just a week and see if your consciousness improves for the rest of the day, even when you're not doing the exercise. The other huge piece of advice I have for people who want to be more present is to actually start the day the way you want to experience the day, which is alive, awake, alert, feeling. The easiest way to not achieve that is, of course, going to your phone the first thing in the moment, you know, as soon as you wake up and just immediately flooding your
证据。所以我确实想让你试一试。如果不管用，那也就是30秒。无论如何你本来也会花这些时间听这一集。所以你其实没什么好失去的。但如果它管用，如果你感受到了哪怕一丝改变，一丝微小的改变，一丝轻微的转变，试着执行它仅仅一周，看看在剩下的时间里你的意识是否有所改善，甚至在你没有做练习的时候也是如此。我给那些想要活在当下的人的另一个巨大建议，其实是以你想要体验这一天的方式开始这一天，那就是充满活力、清醒、警觉、有感觉。而实现这一目标的捷径，当然就是一醒来就在当下抓起手机，你知道的，一醒来就立即用
brain with just like all this like crazy information and I get the impulse I get also that this might be super simple advice but sometimes the smallest change and the smallest reminder to make the smallest change is what is most effective those micro habits have the largest impact and this is certainly a very easy micro habit start the day practicing presence by focusing on your breathing for the first few minutes after you wake up, drinking a cold glass of water and feeling the passage of the water through your body, experiencing sunlight or even a breeze. These are sensory grounding exercises. And the reason that they work is that they very intentionally connect you and what you're thinking with what you're feeling. The way I explain it is like when you sync up audio and video,
所有这些疯狂的信息来淹没你的大脑，我理解这种冲动，我也明白这可能是超级简单的建议，但有时最小的改变和对做出最小改变的最轻微提醒才是最有效的，那些微习惯具有最大的影响力，这绝对是一个非常容易开始的微习惯，在醒来后的最初几分钟通过专注于呼吸来开始一天的正念练习，喝一杯冰水并感受水流过身体的感觉，体验阳光甚至微风。这些都是感官接地练习。它们之所以有效，是因为它们非常有意地将你以及你的想法与你的感受连接起来。我解释它的方式就像当你同步音频和视频时，
you sync up your perception with what is what is actually currently happening and they're aligned. Basically, what we are doing is seeking ways that we can take ourselves from being detached, doing things habitually to doing it deliberately, switching from unremarkable and automatic to remarkable and joyful. In a similar vein, my friend actually introduced me to this method that she calls the romance moment. Basically, the romance moment is where you choose one activity in your day to fully romanticize and be engaged in. Take, you know, brushing your teeth or doing the dishes, really drag it out. Feel every moment, every movement.
你将你的感知与实际正在发生的事情同步，并且它们保持一致。基本上，我们正在做的是寻找方法，使我们能够摆脱脱离现实、习惯性做事的模式，转变为刻意做事，从不引人注目且自动化的状态转变为卓越而快乐的状态。与此类似，我的朋友实际上向我介绍了一种她称之为浪漫时刻的方法。基本上，浪漫时刻就是你选择一天中的一项活动，对其进行完全的浪漫化并全身心投入。比如，刷牙或洗碗，真正地把时间拉长。感受每一个时刻，每一个动作。
Watch what your hands are doing, how your muscles are moving. Every second, fully be in it. A really good way actually, like a great way to try this. is it a meal like when you're sitting down for dinner or breakfast really savour each bite each new taste pause for three seconds between each bite you know like that research paper said before you've got to savor the moment you've got to really be in the moment for all that it's worth and i think also avoiding that multitasking is also really really valuable i think it's very hard to do that we're very busy people but just try and focus on one
观察你的手在做什么，你的肌肉是如何运动的。每一秒，完全置身其中。实际上一个非常好的方法，比如尝试这个的好方法，是在用餐时，当你坐下来吃晚餐或早餐时，真正品尝每一口，每一个新的味道，在每两口之间停顿三秒钟，你知道的，就像那篇研究论文之前说的，你必须品尝这一时刻，你必须为了它所值的一切真正置身于当下。而且我认为避免多任务处理也是非常非常有价值的，我认为这很难做到，我们都是非常忙碌的人，但请试着一次只专注于
thing at once. The biggest difficulty I do here is with being present, especially in this day and age, is how many distractions there are. And I think we've all had that experience of like, we're talking to a friend or our friend is talking to us and like a phone is buzzing. And there's someone walking past who's like wearing an outfit that you like. And the music is too loud. And it's just like, there's just a lot going on. And my to do list is getting longer and longer by the second. You've got a million things to do. You're anxious about the future. You're thinking about that weird exchange from yesterday and there is that societal push to be busy and stretch thin. Going against that and focusing on one thing at a time is actually very bold and actually
一件事。我在这里听到的关于活在当下的最大困难，尤其是在这个时代，是有太多的干扰了。我想我们都有过这样的经历，我们在和朋友说话，或者朋友在对我们说话，然后手机在震动。有个穿着你喜欢衣服的人从旁边走过。音乐太大声了。而且就是，事情实在太多了。我的待办事项清单以每秒钟的速度变得越来越长。你有一百万件事要做。你对未来感到焦虑。你在想着昨天那个奇怪的交流，并且社会有一种推动你去忙碌、把自己拉得很薄的压力。逆势而上，一次专注于一件事，实际上是非常大胆的，而且
very, very effective, especially when we've been conditioned to go through life, kind of like we're operating the landing strip at a busy airport. Like anything that's around us, anything that's happening like, you're welcome in, come in, distract me. slow it down. Embrace single tasking by limiting how many tabs you have open on your desktop, limiting notifications, setting time blocks, 20 minutes for each thing where you are fully concentrated, and then you can shift. Do the hardest and most mentally draining tasks first thing, and then move on to the smaller bite-sized things that you can take off later in the day as your intentional resources kind of deplete.
非常非常有效，尤其是当我们已经被习惯于这样度过一生：就像我们在繁忙的机场运营着降落伞着陆跑道一样。周围的任何事，发生的任何事，都像是，欢迎光临，进来吧，分散我的注意力。慢下来。通过限制你在桌面上打开的标签页数量、限制通知、设置时间块来拥抱单任务处理，每件事20分钟，在此期间你完全集中精力，然后你就可以切换。把最困难、最耗费脑力的任务放在第一位做，然后再转向随着你的一天中注意力资源消耗而可以在当天晚些时候勾掉的较小的、易于处理的事情。
there are so many strategies for this. I know the inclination is to be doing it all and you can, just not all at once. And we're seeing this research time and time again that if what you're worried about is productivity, is getting everything done, hitting milestones, achieving goals, actually being intentional, being really attentive on one thing at once with your time is a much more successful strategy. Staying in the present really allows you to tap into that secret pool, that secret like mental pool, mental lake, like everything that makes you a successful person. You know, purpose, creativity, kindness, attention, awareness, self-awareness. That all comes from living in the moment rather than feeling like everything is just this tangled web
有太多的策略可以做到这一点。我知道人们倾向于把所有事情都做了，你也可以，只是不能同时做。我们一次又一次地看到这项研究表明，如果你担心的是生产力，是完成所有事情，达到里程碑，实现目标，那么实际上保持专注，在同一时间只用你的时间专注并高度关注一件事，是一个成功得多的策略。留在当下确实能让你接入那个秘密的源泉，那个秘密的心理源泉，心理之湖，所有造就你成功之人的因素。你知道的，目标、创造力、善良、注意力、觉察、自我觉察。这一切都来自于活在当下，而不是觉得一切都只是这个错综复杂的网络
of before, after, during, what's on my to-do list? What could possibly go wrong over thinking? Try and just detangle that web. And I want to recommend this one final thing for you, which is actually a book. And it's called The Power of Now. My friend, Kate, one of my best friends, Kay, who I talk about on the podcast a lot, she's fabulous. She's amazing.
关于过去、未来、期间，我的待办事项清单上有什么？可能会出什么问题，过度思考。试着解开这个网络。我想向你推荐最后一件事情，实际上是一本书。它叫《当下的力量》。我的朋友凯特，我的最好朋友之一凯特，我在播客里经常提到她，她太棒了。她太惊艳了。
I love her. She actually bought me this book for my birthday a few years back. And it's very new age and spiritual, which I never truly gravitated. towards because I'm much more, I think, scientific personally. But I packed it on a holiday and it was incredible. It deeply changed my personal philosophy. It made me think about my life differently. I think it's probably the inspiration for this episode.
我爱她。几年前她实际上给我买这本书作为生日礼物。它是非常新时代和精神层面的，我以前从未真正被它吸引，因为就我个人而言，我认为我更倾向于科学。但我把它塞进行李带去度假，结果令人难以置信。它深刻地改变了我的个人哲学。它让我对生活有了不同的思考。我想这大概就是这一集的灵感来源。
And although it's about 30 years old now, there is this saying that the author has that has always really stuck with me and it's that only the present moment is real and only the present moment is what matters. The past is the past or future. You don't know what it's going to be. So the only thing that you can truly experience is what you're going through right now. And that just always kind of wakes me up a little bit. It always gives me something to think about.
尽管它现在已经有大约30年的历史了，但作者有一句话一直深深地触动着我，那就是只有当下才是真实的，只有当下才是重要的。过去就是过去，或者是未来。你不知道它会是什么样。所以你真正能体验到的只有你现在正在经历的事情。这总是能把我稍微唤醒一点。它总是给我一些思考的东西。
So if you want to expand your mindset when it comes to mindfulness, when it comes to the power of now, the power of the present, that book I would really, really recommend. So thank you so much for listening to this episode if you have made it this far. It's great to have you here at the very end, as we're summarizing. I just hope that, you know, I think I said this at the end of every episode, but I hope that you just go away thinking about something, learning something, even if it was small.
所以，如果你想拓展自己关于正念的心态，关于当下的力量，当下的力量，那本书我真的、真的很推荐。所以如果你坚持到了这一步，非常感谢你收听这一集。很高兴你能在最后时刻来到这里，当我们正在总结时。我只希望，你知道的，我想我在每一集的结尾都说过这句话，但我希望你离开时能思考一些事情，学到一些东西，哪怕它很小。
This is like a topic that I'm in a subject, I guess, that I'm really, really feeling the importance of in my own life at the moment. If you couldn't tell by how much I referenced my own anxiety and my own, I think, tendency to be rushing and to be filling my life with so many distractions that I never really have to feel. The power of staying present is an important reminder for me. So yeah, I hope it's the same for you. And then if you enjoyed this episode, make sure that you are following along on Spotify, Apple Podcasts, leave a five-star review only if you feel cool to do so. Otherwise, don't even have to worry about it. And if there's someone that you think would also
这是一个话题，或者说一个主题，我目前在自己的生活中非常强烈地感受到它的重要性。如果你从我对自身焦虑的引用频率，以及我认为自己倾向于匆忙行事并用如此多的 distractions（干扰）填满生活以至于永远不必去感受的倾向中看不出来的话。保持当下的力量对我是个重要的提醒。所以，是的，我希望对你也是如此。然后，如果你喜欢这一集，请确保你在Spotify、Apple Podcasts上关注，留下五星好评，前提是你觉得有必要这样做的话。否则，甚至不用担心。如果有人你也认为会
benefit from this episode. Please feel free to share a link with them. You can also DM me on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast and give us a follow. If you want to see what we've got coming out soon, if you want to contribute to the discussion, if you have thoughts, feelings, questions, I would love to hear from you. And until Friday, stay safe, stay kind. Be gentle with yourself and we will talk very, very soon. 2%.
从中受益。请随时与他们分享链接。你也可以在Instagram上私信我 @That Psychology Podcast 并给我们点个关注。如果你想看看我们即将推出什么内容，如果你想参与讨论，如果你有想法、感受、问题，我很乐愿听到你的声音。在周五之前，保持安全，保持善良。对自己温柔一点，我们很快很快就会再聊。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships,
这就是在也有自动扶梯可用的情况下选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，
and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a podcast.
你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。也就是数字的TWO%。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回顾一下》（Look Back at）播客中。
From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year.
从1979年开始，那对我和对我来说是一个重要时刻。84年对我也很重要。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ（Alex English）。每一集，我们选择一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过它的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的人以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。
I mean, it was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor?
我的意思是，那是一个疯狂的一年。我认为没有比这更重要的一年对于黑人而言了。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾一下》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？正在收听《艰难学习》（Learn the Hard Way），由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）主持。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在任何地方真的都不安全，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？
It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力并不意味着你需要这样做，在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习》。2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，欧文斯女士，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭开一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens. finally faces consequences.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉利斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。保证是由真人制作的。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子来留下评论。